let's go to the 805 area code caller
from 805 go ahead all right hey this is
Rick and I'm actually calling you from
Geneva Switzerland oh very cool all
right go ahead Rick so have a a question
for you
earlier this morning just a few hours
ago the US Air Force launched a
Minuteman ICBMs Burgh air force base to
the Marshall Islands and you know this
comes obviously right before the Moon
kin summit which is religious hours away
so just wondering what your take is on
what's going on here do you think that
there's sort of an active effort to send
a message before that summit or do you
think this is like just an inability to
communicate between the military and our
diplomat I would say probably all of the
above combined with I don't know if you
saw Rick but there's a report that right
around the time that we heard from North
Korea that they were going to
denuclearize which of course the Trump
administration made a very very big deal
about that their nuclear facility
effectively collapsed and that it might
not have been something that they
decided to do out of sort of diplomatic
prowess or calculation but rather
something that they figured hey we've
sustained major damage to this facility
maybe at this point rather than rebuild
let's try to get sort of like political
benefit from it so I think that all of
the above is the answer we've seen total
lack of communication between the sort
of diplomatic side of the Trump
administration and the military side
remember when Trump announced the
transgender military ban on Twitter Jim
mattis was like on vacation and had no
idea that it was coming and also didn't
agree and eventually said we're not even
going to do it so I think there is a
total disconnect right now between
military diplomacy the Oval Office and
it's very very hard to really figure out
what it is that's going on there yeah
absolutely and you know my my big
concern is if if we are expecting and
hoping for North Korea to cease its
missile program and obviously its ICBM
testing that perhaps we should at least
postpone ours while these negotiations
are taking place that's interesting how
would that like how would that be
structured diplomatically though oh well
I mean III think that that the US could
just not conduct ICBM test well while
the negotiations are taking place I mean
I don't know what's going to go down I
don't know what's going to go down
between the u.s. and North Korea and
South Korea in terms of structuring a
deal to these North Korea's programs but
but you know something is definitely
possible I guess what I mean Rick is
what what I mean is the following which
is if the United States stops ICBM tests
and doesn't mention that they're
officially stopping them during the
summit it's sort of of no value if they
do say that they're going to do it it
could be one of those things that
someone with Trump's foreign policy
mentality to the extent that he has one
perceives as a sort of like weakness or
precondition which is also something
that is land for so I just see it as
difficult diplomatically sure no well
yeah I see what you mean and in in my
opinion I think that just stopping it
not saying anything about it yeah I
think there's really nothing lost there
it's not spinning in someone's eye yeah
you know I think you're probably right I
think you probably right I don't know
that it's gonna happen I appreciate the
call Rick thank you all right yeah thank
you all right very good